for those of you at home uh this is
absolutely fascinating hi there i'm seth
rogan and i'm nick offerman we are uh
unpaid guest correspondents for wired
and today we are reviewing
crafting gadgets
[Music]
so let's see what wired has in store for
us today
[Music]
cool
magnetic wristband if you're looking for
a unique and practical tool look no
further
need a screw bam bam need a nail we got
you looking for nuts and bolts just look
down because with the soft digit
magnetic wristband everything you need
for your next diy project is right at
your fingertips
uh max said wow i feel like magneto but
then he says could be happier is i don't
know if that's a reflection on feeling
like magneto because he himself is an
unhappy man i feel like magneto could be
happier five stars
jimothy said great name
[Music]
doesn't work at all
my nuts and bolts keep falling off and i
was on my ladder and i had to go up and
down my ladder 400 times terrible
product also my ladder broke
one star
i don't know if you could put the ladder
failure off this product necessarily
probably be careful of your chair yes
it seems good you got to make sure
you're not doing it on your hammer hand
i would imagine right does anyone hear
with both hands is that a thing i've
done it but it was i was i had to train
not advisable you got me thinking you
know if
i hammer with this hand yeah so uh you
want to be able to access your hardware
yeah with your holding hand but if you
do that then you're going to be when
you're swinging the hammer i think you
run the risk of this flying off no i
would have it with my i would have it in
the hand i'm holding the nails with i
would imagine right but then you're
saying it's cumbersome to be pulling it
off with one hand and then you're
transferring it back to the magnetized
hand you have to switch the hammer to
this hand yeah
you're getting a lot of back and forth
lots of back and forth in there i get it
[Music]
i think it's pretty cool never i don't i
i myself do not do nearly enough uh
of this type of thing to require this
type of thing i'm doing one nail i'd
give this five stars this seems to do
exactly what you would hope to do i
think i'm with max i feel like magneto
in that i could be happier while i don't
think this is necessary i would give it
three
and a half stars
[Music]
what
um okay introducing the yukto sun head
mount magnifier with two led
professional jewelers light brackets see
your text magnified up to 350 of the
original size with high clarity perfect
for jewelry work watch repair arts and
crafts or as a general reading aid
future doctor said
perfect
everything about this is just the best
i can see
so close
and i was able to
fix my watch anybody that there's a
spelling here
which my dog broke and now my watch is
better than ever wow five stars that's
from a future doctor well john c
riley i assume says
so uncomfortable my head hurt again
spelling mistake
after using for one word five minutes if
i can't wear it for five minutes what's
the point john c reilly has a point he
says one star
it makes me feel like i'm in a movie
where i'm defusing a bomb well i can
already tell you right now if you also
wear glasses i don't know what to do
with this thing
it is actually pretty effective right
now as i look at it
it's rad as hell
i love this thing i've i've gotten old
enough that i need to wear reading
glasses and so i'm seeing your mouth
move very very closely i can do i can do
fine work with this
[Music]
out of five i'll give i'll give it wow
four stars this is freaking cool i could
use this too wait did i did i say
uh four stars
you did did you mean five
now now it's fine
mine doesn't work zero star so that's a
that's a that's a strike against the
light doesn't come on so i'd say that's
bad so
i think i have to give it one star
because if i bought these and the light
didn't work i'd be pissed do you give
stars for potential
[Music]
oh hello hell yes
knee blades wesley snipes is
the miles craft 1603 knee blades rolling
knee pads are the perfect addition
to any tool box and that is a euphemism
clean bathroom said
so good
i used to hate cleaning my bathroom of
course
which was the bait of my existence as a
person named clean bathroom
not anymore love love love love the d
blades
uh clean bathroom gives it five stars
cool guy
1987 said
wheels broke colon
the wheels broke
not cool
and if there's one thing cool guy in
1987 hates
it's something that's not cool one star
not cool
they're pretty good do you feel these
are solving a problem that maybe a lot
of people don't have yeah i feel like
are they for painting no because yeah
you can kind of if your knees are really
padded you don't need these [ __ ]
wheels you don't need the wheels that's
the thing like if i saw i assume other
construction workers make fun of the guy
with uh right we need knee blades
[Music]
man if you're like skeeching behind your
dad's station wagon
i i say four stars maybe a three and a
half stars they feel a little cheap if
i'm being honest
oh man i hope i get 20 20 25
i'm i'm gonna go i think they're taking
us for a ride whoa you know you don't
trust these people
talking about words that don't roll off
the tongue look at the brand of this
thing ardinskos sometimes it's just too
hard to know how wet your wood is
um never worry about that again with the
redinscose wood moisture meter with its
easy to read lcd screen you'll never
wonder how moisture wood is again dwayne
says accurate i think seems accurate
least consistent nothing to test it
again so who knows five stars lumberman
said not sensitive enough to measure
small humidity
do you measure the humidity i didn't
know this was a thing you know uh
depending on the season how your cabinet
door will get stuck uh-huh that's
because the wood expands and contracts
so if i'm using hardware or if i'm
joining two pieces together you have to
take that into account
oh holy [ __ ]
do it there you go so you could also
kill someone with it
you can very slowly yeah
this comes in as high that's very moist
wood this is very wet yeah ideally for
furniture making you want eight to
eleven percent okay firewood you want
fifteen to twenty percent and so you
don't want this wet wood for for
anything no this is
that's what's due wet it's too wet this
is only telling me the moisture you know
basically at the surface and so you also
need to know what's down in the in the
center of that
[Music]
i'd say
without any further testing uh i would
optimistically give that a four that's
pretty good the uh the green uh lcd
screen is pleasant it is very nice
this pottery machine the tactic electric
pottery wheel is suitable for many
projects you can make special gifts for
your family and friends during holidays
a great gift for any occasion natasha
said
get this wheel
five stars mr man
says very sad very sad
mine arrived with a visibly bent shaft
causing a thump on each rotation that's
not good nobody could be more
disappointed nobody could be more
disappointed
he was really looking forward to this
thing one star
on
forward
okay
interesting
it's hard to say it's for very short
people it's like a good i guess
beginners pottery wheel pottery wheels
can be pretty expensive like most potter
wheels are like made so you can build
something that's like hundreds of pounds
what's the upper limit of pounds you
usually work in i'd say like high teens
would be like a very big thing i mean
it's not bad for smaller things honestly
i may be a novice but i believe this is
a vessel it is a vessel i can make a
little vase here
i think the 200 bucks this is very good
if you're just starting to see if it's
something you want to invest more time
and energy in basically this doesn't
feel that different than it feels to
throw on like a pretty big expensive
wheel honestly it's pretty it's pretty
good if you're just doing this little
stuff for those of you at home uh this
is absolutely fascinating
watching someone make something with his
hands uh
look at that this is good at
it's gorgeous
we call that
the garrote
[Laughter]
i'd give this for 200
five stars
all right that's it that's all five
gadgets this is wired correspondent
signing off until next time
[Music]